die industrie hat es geschafft das image
des einst so als unberührt natürlich
rein aufzubauen für mich mittlerweile
genau das gegenteil davon ausbeutung und
leid
wir wollen wissen wie viel bio steckten
bio es ist eine totale lüge
das ist etikettenschwindel wir schauen
uns an wie die zustände in bio
legehennen anlagen sind und werden
schockierendes finden wir zeigen dass
bio nicht gleich bio ist und mit welchen
legalen tricks sicher fabrikanten das
biosiegel erschleichen
[Musik]
jährlich werden in deutschland rund 1,1
milliarden bio eier gegessen
eine stolze zahl und diese eier müssen
ja auch erst mal gelegt werden um als
bio zu gelten dürfen eigentlich nur 3000
hühner in einem stall gehalten werden
doch in der realität ist das nur selten
der fall
zum beispiel brandenburg tier stammen 90
prozent der bio eier aus
massenproduktion
doch wie kann massenproduktion gleich
bio sein
laut eu verordnung erhalten eier an bio
siegel unter folgenden bedingungen sechs
hühner leben auf einem quadratmeter
stall
dazu muss es vier quadratmeter auslauf
pro huhn geben und ausschließlich bio
futter tricksen die massenhersteller
oder sind alle bio-eier wirklich bio
sie bilde keitel und thomas preuß
engagieren sich seit jahren in einer
bürgerinitiative gegen den bau einer
konventionellen legehennenanlage in
ihrem ort vor allem in der
brandenburgischen uckermark gibt es
immer mehr bauanträge für riesige
legehennenanlage auch für bio eier
bio ist der absolute trend und bio
scheint also die große zauberformel zu
sein um sich ein gutes gewissen zu
verschaffen und da setzen natürlich
jetzt auch die großen ketten drauf und
das bio aber nicht zum preis von
ramschware zu haben es wird jetzt
langsam immer mehr enthüllt
jedes ei hat einen zahlencode stempel
damit lässt sich herausfinden woher das
ei stammt
unsere bilder keitel macht genau das sie
haben bei verschiedenen discountern bio
eier gekauft und gehen nun auf die suche
was für ein betrieb hinter dem steckt 17
33 51 das ist gerade auch kontrolliert
biologischer erzeugung
da sieht man ganz deutlich wie
abgefressen vertreten
die auslauffläche ist dass er kaum noch
grün ist die satellitenbilder zeigen
hier leben nicht nur 3000 hühner
das sieht nach agrarindustrie und nicht
nach bio hof aus die anlage liegt im
norden von brandenburg
sie bilde keitel und frank preuß wollen
sich vor ort ein bild machen
laut einer liste des landes brandenburg
werden hier fast 40.000 hühner gehalten
gar nicht eigentlich dürfen es nur 3000
hühner pro bio steil sein
doch die eier fabrikanten nutzen einen
baulichen trick sie unterteilen einen
riesigen stall in einzelnen abteile mit
jeweils 3.000 hennen jedes abteil hat
auch seinen eigenen auslaufbereich somit
können ohne probleme
zehntausende hühner auf einem hof
gehalten werden und erfüllen trotzdem
den bierstand nicht sehen aber man ahnt
furchtbares
auf nachfrage zu den haltungsbedingungen
antwortet uns die betreiberfirma die
haltung unserer bio hühner erfolgt nach
den strengen bio richtlinien die eu weit
gelten
das aneinanderreihen von abgetrennten
stahlteilen ist in ganz deutschland
sowie in der eu überall anzutreffen und
entspricht der eu verordnung
es gibt keinen nachweis auf einen
positiven effekt auf tiere wenn die
tiere in kleineren stadtteilen gehalten
werden doch bio heißt auch nicht
automatisch dass es den hühnern gut geht
so sei es in einem deutschen bio stall
aus gefilmt wurden diese bilder von
animal rights watch einer
tierschutzorganisation seit mittlerweile
acht jahren denken sie immer wieder
missstände in bio eier großanlagen auf
bilder die man eher aus der
konventionellen massentierhaltung
erwartet doch hier wurden wirklich bio
eier produziert wir haben untereinander
diskutiert weil wir wie gesagt haben
immer wenn wir einen konventionellen
betrieb veröffentlichen dann sagen ganz
viele leute ja aber bio tierhaltung ist
die lösung der probleme da geht es den
tieren gut und deswegen haben wir damals
2012 gesagt na gut dann filme jetzt bio
stelle ich möchte meinen namen nicht
gerne sagen nur weil ich es nicht mag
wenn man über lange jahre dann im
internet noch mit seinem namen finden
ist und dort sehr viel hass kommentare
dann mit mir persönlich verbunden werden
die tierschützer sind im herbst 2009 10
in brandenburg unterwegs
wir haben uns für den hof entschieden
weil es gibt eine goldgräberstimmung
gerade bio legehennenbetriebe
aufzuziehen die kadaver tonne lässt
schlimmes erahnen
sie ist randvoll mit toten hin
ja das ist die haltung also
dann ist es nichts anderes als
bodenhaltung und tagsüber wenn ich hier
raus können dann ist es ja die
freilandhaltung mit dem unterschied dass
ein bio futter gefüttert wird
hier ist jetzt die tür zum nächsten teil
[Musik]
da kommen die nächsten 3000
also das ist das worum es geht das was
man hier sieht es dann jetzt die alten
drin also dann scheide ich es nicht von
konventioneller haltung
man hat diese metallregale man hat unten
ihren staubigen zunehmend zum wurde
geboren
ich bin halt immer wieder fassungslos
dass das halt wirklich von den leuten
als bio abgekauft wird also die leute
kaufen hier ein supermarkt produkt
packung wo irgend eine grüne wiese drauf
ist und irgendwie zwei hühner und ein
hahn oder so und denken okay man habe
ich mein geld extra für bezahlt dass ich
jetzt ein gutes gewissen habe aber das
ist halt in wirklichkeit bio die werden
jetzt hier für ein jahr als läge
maschinen benutzt legen auch in der bio
haltung 303 ungefähr in diesem jahr dann
lässt die legeleistung nach dann werden
wir also braucht man aber diese nun
schon so ein bisschen das geht halt
schon so in richtung geruch des suchen
haben für mich zeigen diese aufnahmen
diese regale diese tausenden von tieren
auf diesen metall regalen dass es sich
eigentlich für uns menschen nur
maschinen handelt
[Musik]
und auch so kann bio aussehen hier auf
diesem bauernhof in seelow in
mecklenburg vorpommern auf dem hof von
anna und lukas prob leben 6600
legehennen auch diese eier haben das bio
gütesiegel bei uns leben glücklich
erinnert
sie leben hier wesens gemäss unser
leitspruch ist ja so ein bisschen kenne
deine hände
das ist natürlich schon so dass wir
nicht alle unsere 6600 händen persönlich
kennen aber es ist etwas dahinter steht
die tiere sind in zwei mobilen ställen
untergebracht
der auslauf ist immer wieder woanders so
kann sich der boden erholen und die
hühner werden weniger krank weil sie
nicht im eigenen dreck schaffen müssen
generell entspricht es absolut nicht
meine philosophie was heutzutage halt
bio legehennenhaltung mit sich zieht an
ganz vielen stellen dass wenn man sagt
man möchte an discounter liefern dann
kriegst du diktierte und sophie cent
kriegst du für dein déi und dann
überlegst du dir vor mit 6000 enden wird
das ein bisschen knapp meine über 30.000
legehennen dann rechnet sich das auf
ihrem hof arbeiten zehn leute die sich
um die hühner kümmern
in den biomassen tieranlagen arbeiten
mancherorts nur zwei arbeitskräfte bei
30.000 legehennen wir liefern quasi die
bilder wie sich der verbraucher das
vorstellt und dann denkt er wenn es bei
dem so aussieht und dann wird sowohl
über ihr auch so aussehen
bei uns steht auf der verpackung genau
wie beim discounter sechs bio eier auf
der packung steht da steht das gleiche
drauf natürlich ist das nicht fair aber
das ist ja der markt in dem wir uns
bewegen 2021 wird das neue eu bio recht
in kraft treten
doch die unterteilung von riesigen
hühnerställen bleibt auch dann weiterhin
erlaubt mit dem willen der politik und
so müssen wir uns selbst fragen wie bio
sind discounter bio eier wirklich fühlt
ihr euch getäuscht vom bio siegel
schreibt es uns in die kommentare